♪
Has an adult asked you,
"What do you want to be?"
That's a really tough question.
I'm only in middle school.
Each of us have strengths.
Superpowers help find out
what is important to us.
So what are they?
And how do kids
find a career?
We'll help you explore
those superpowers.
If you use them every day,
work might not seem like work.
Let's meet people at Qualcomm's
World of Work and get started.
Take it away, Team!
(woman)
Good morning, good morning.
Welcome to Qualcomm.
(man)
We're in
the World of Work room.
All students start
their experience here
at the Thinkabit Lab.
Essentially,
it's a place for kids
to learn about work and all
the careers we have at Qualcomm.
Who would know that there are
engineers, marketers, lawyers,
and people who work in HR.
There's people
that work in facilities,
plumbers, electricians,
all kinds of different jobs.
So how do you find out
about those careers?
You come to
the World of Work room.
People, as they get older,
they want great jobs.
They want to be excited
about their work.
You're going to work,
on average,
60,000 hours
in your lifetime.
That's a long time.
Let's do some simple math.
The average individual works
2,080 hours a year,
and you're probably
going to work for 30 years.
Right there,
you get 60,000 hours.
So if you start
thinking about it earlier,
you may have a better chance
of finding that sweet job,
the thing that really fits you.
We do an exercise on various
careers here at Qualcomm,
but you can also
find these careers
at large tech companies
all throughout the world.
So they'll get
a ring of careers.
They'll look
at these careers.
They might identify
with the career title.
(Ed)
When you go from
the job title on the front
and look on the back,
you're going to see
a job description
that tells you about
what they would do,
wages, how much
these people make,
like what do these people earn.
Is that job expected
to be in demand?
What kind of degree
do I need?
Do I need a four-year degree,
a master's, or maybe a PhD?
Do I want to be
in school that long?
That's a question
you need to ask yourself.
(Jennifer)
I'm going to read
statements, okay?
If feel like, "Yeah,
that sounds like me,"
then stay standing.
If you're like,
"No, that's not for me,
I'm not interested,"
then just take a seat.
Once you've taken a seat,
you can't stand back up, okay?
(Ed)
The stand-up exercise
is something we do every day.
As you're seeing people at work
performing their jobs,
you might want
to be thinking,
"Is this a stand-up
or sit-down for me?"
(Jennifer)
"I see myself wearing a uniform
every day to work."
"I like that I'll be
walking and standing
throughout my day at work."
"I am okay
with having to work nights,
weekends, and holidays."
[laughter]
"I can make
critical decisions
if someone's life
is depending on me."
And the last prompt,
"I can handle seeing someone
if they're in pain."
[laughs]
So the two
that are standing,
what do you think
potentially this career is?
Like a doctor
or a hospital medic.
Excellent, excellent.
It is a critical care nurse.
Great job.
The world of work
is all around you.
How do we notice
what's happening around us?
And you can be
asking yourself,
"Is this a stand-up for me
or a sit-down?"
It's always okay to sit down.
It's always okay
to sit on the sidelines.
But it's important to
put yourself out on the field
and stand up and say,
"That's for me."
On your whiteboard,
make three different categories.
It's going to be strengths,
interests, and values.
If there was a career
or opportunity
that you might be
interested in now,
if you had to get a job today,
what might be some things
that would interest you?
When I say strengths,
it's what are you good at.
What are you good at?
Be selfish.
Really dream big.
(Ed)
Strengths are found in all.
Sometimes it's hard to
figure out what we are good at.
Are people telling us that?
Know what you do well.
That's what a strength is.
Make a list, maybe like three
or four different strengths.
I have over here
some examples.
If you're an achiever--
you make lists
and talk about things
you want to aspire to--
you're probably categorized as
someone who likes to achieve.
If responsibility is
very important to you,
you follow the rules
or make sure that
we're all taken care of,
that might be
a strength of yours
that makes you maybe
a little bit unique.
It could be something
you've done really well,
whether it's in school,
with your family,
whether it's with
your friends,
it's with
your community.
What's one of your strengths?
Yeah.
Math.
You enjoy math.
Excellent, excellent.
Quick thinking
You're a sharp thinker.
Great.
Risk taking.
Taking risks.
Research.
Doing research.
Okay.
Interests are things we love,
things we care about.
Do we like working with animals,
with people, with numbers?
Those are the questions
you should be asking yourself.
What do I find myself
doing regularly?
Do I take things apart,
like machines?
Do I like math? Do I like
baking, cooking, or dancing?
Those are clues to things
we want to do later in life.
If you could give me three
or four various interests,
in a career lens,
if you thought of a job,
what might that be?
What are your interests? Yeah.
Engineering.
Engineering, okay.
Yeah.
Coast Guard or Navy.
You're interested
in the Navy.
Programming or hardware.
Programming or interested
in working with hardware.
Marine biology.
Military and vet.
Military and
being a veterinarian.
These are your interests.
They might change.
And the last category
is values, okay?
This is what's important to you.
What's like a deal breaker?
When I said working nights,
weekends, and holidays,
some of you sat down
immediately, right?
That might be flexible
and might not bother you.
Maybe you want to do nights
and weekends for double pay.
Everyone's going to have
different values.
If work-life balance
is important
or spending time with family,
write down some of
your personal values.
This is in a lens of a career.
Values in a career.
Maybe you want to work for
a company that makes an impact.
It is doing good in the world.
Something that's a value to you.
Values are those nonnegotiables
that we have sometimes in life,
if we didn't have to
give up things
that are important to us.
Knowing how you're wired
around your values
also gives you some clues
to what job
might be right for you.
Each of you have
different values.
Give me two or three
different values
that would be
very important to you
at your job
or at your career.
All right, looks like
we've got a great long list.
What are some values?
If needed,
take risks for others.
Okay, in the back.
How about getting
the same pay as men?
All right, that's a value.
Excellent.
Teamwork?
Teamwork.
Excellent
Making people happy.
You have three
distinct categories.
This is you right now.
It might change.
I can guarantee
when you're in high school,
it might change,
and that's okay.
The whole goal of this is
to take a self-assessment
of who you are now
and see like,
"This is important to me.
"This is a career I aspire to.
"This is something I'm good at
and confident in.
Someone's told me that.
It feels right."
The big takeaway is that
this could be a reality for you.
When you're in your
dream job or career,
not looking at the watch,
feeling like,
"When do I get to go home?"
and you're just being you,
that's when you've aligned
your strengths, interests,
and values.
That should be the goal.
You've worked hard
on your education
to deploy those talents,
to express your interests,
and to make sure your values
are being matched
wherever you're working.
Whether we're out at
a restaurant or sporting event,
somebody is working there
as part of that experience.
So we've learned to take note.
Who's doing what?
Who's doing what really well?
Is there anything that someone's
doing that might interest me?
Anytime you leave your front
door, keep your eyes open,
and you might find a job
that's interesting.
When you're going throughout
your day observing,
whether it's your teacher,
family member,
when you're out and about,
when you someone happy, joyful,
and engaged in their work,
it's important to take note of
and what is it.
Why are they engaged?
What makes them so happy?
If you want to know
about a career
and want to ask an adult,
just ask politely.
An adult is just waiting
to be able to answer
a question about their career.
As a student,
you're missing opportunities
if you're not willing to ask
a teacher or your principal,
maybe a friend of your mom
and dad or your family,
ask them, "Do you like your job?
How did you get your job?
"What do you hate
about your job?
"If there was one thing
you hate about your job,
what would it be?"
You want to learn all about
the good and the bad.
Adults are waiting to get
that question from a student.
Thanks, Team.
Thanks for hanging out with us
to learn about careers.
Hopefully you learned simple
things to help decide
your direction
in the work world.
When someone asks,
"What do you want to be?"
you'll have tools to use
to help figure it out.
See you next time.
Funding to purchase and make
this educational production
accessible was provided by the
U.S. Department of Education:
PH: 1-800-USA-LEARN (V)
or WEB: www.ed.gov.